when you love something you fight for it
[Music]
we're the ones who change everything
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we have
a ton of new footage coming directly
from
marvel studios including our first look
at the eternals
now this is actually a pretty cool thing
that marvel studios did this morning
they put out a
trailer titled marvel studios celebrates
the movies
they recapped a lot of great movies and
moments from the mcu that we've seen so
far and then they started
a new trailer kind of inside the trailer
for all of their upcoming shows
in which we got new footage for the
eternals black widow and
shang qi we also got the titles for some
upcoming projects and
their release dates so i'll be breaking
down the eternals teaser in this video
as it's our first time
seeing them and we'll just do shot by
shot here and talk about what exactly
we're seeing and who the eternals are
so we have a little bit of footage it
goes by pretty quickly but that's what a
teaser is
it starts off by showing us salma
hayek's character ajax she's on a horse
and it seems like she could be on some
type of
ranch we then hear a voice say when you
love something
you fight for it we then immediately see
two hands and then it pans out to show
the eternals in their actual
eternal suits throughout this footage we
see them dressed normally and
in their eternals outfits and i'll
explain why that is in just a bit
but the camera pans out and we see some
of the eternals
on the very left we have barry keegan's
character druid
druid is an eternal of course and he's
actually the cousin of another eternal
icarus who we see later on in the
trailer
although he isn't always good in fact in
the comics he actually
tortured his cousin icarus and he is
actually rumored to be
one of the villains of this movie
betraying the other eternals
then to his right we see lauren
ridloff's character makari
in the comics makari is actually a male
character so they did a gender swap here
makari has the typical powers of an
eternal like superhuman strength speed
immortality
matter manipulation etc i'll get to that
in just a bit but
makari is actually the eternals's
technology guy and he's even a member of
the eternal's technologist
guild and he designed some pretty cool
things for the eternals like very high
speed vehicles
then to the right of makari in the
middle we have sprite
now sprite although centuries years old
is stuck with the body of an 11 year old
unable to grow up
sprite is known as the trickster of the
eternal's family
he often taunts his fellow eternals with
illusions and he's been kind of picking
on humans for centuries
and then to the person whose hand sprite
is holding it appears that we have
cersei played by jimmy chan
cersei is kind of known for causing a
little bit of trouble with the eternals
searsia is actually pretty fond of
humans and spends a lot of time in the
real world with them
she also has a relationship with dane
whitman aka the black knight who is
going to be played by
kit harrington who is not featured in
this teaser then to the right of
seriously we have
angelina jolie's character athena dina
is a scholar and
she's the warrior of the group we even
get this brief footage of her a little
bit later on of her wielding her sword
going up against somebody whose back has
turned to us now athena has a bit
of a crazy story in the comics the
eternals were created by the celestial
gods but so were the deviants but the
deviants and the eternals go at war with
each other and hate each other however
athena and the deviant crow
actually fall in love with each other
and end up having a baby
actually too she has twins and thena
actually keeps this a secret from the
rest of her eternals and she puts the
babies inside of an infertile human
woman now it's unclear on whether or not
we're going to be seeing this story in
the movie but i do think tina is going
to have a very
very key role to play in the eternals
film one that we're probably not
expecting
and then to athena's right we have
fastos played by brian terry
henry now fastos is kind of the engineer
of the eternals family
he has the ability to create whatever he
can imagine
if he has the materials to build it he
can build it and he creates many
different weapons for the eternals
however his attitude in the comics is
kind of different from the other
eternals he kind of believes life to be
meaningless and he's been searching for
someone or something
to give him meaning in life we then cut
to another scene where we see
richard madden for the very first time
richard madden is playing the eternal
icarus
icarus is one of the leaders of the
eternals and he's kind of like the steve
rogers of the avengers
he has great morals he's very kind he's
charismatic and he likes to keep the
other
eternals safe just an overall really
great guy and he is one of the main
characters of the movie
then in the same scene all the way on
the right we get our first look at don
lee's character
gilgamesh gilgamesh is a beast he's
essentially the juggernaut of the
eternals
in ancient times he actually roamed
earth and helped the human beings by
overthrowing tyrants and killing
dangerous beasts he was often mistaken
for
and called hercules then in the same
shot if we go
all the way to the left we can see kamil
najiyani's character
kingo now kingo's character in the
comics is actually from japan and he's
kind of like a samurai
however that has changed in the eternals
film we actually know that in the
eternals film kingo
is going to be from india and he's
actually going to be a bollywood star
as i'm about to explain in a bit the
eternals actually live amongst the
humans and it looks like kingo has taken
full advantage of being an eternal
because he is a famous person
a famous bollywood actor camille
nanjiani actually revealed this in an
interview not too long ago
we have the scene that i already
mentioned with angelina jolie holding
her sword
then we have a scene with some of the
eternals in front of an ancient
castle now as i already mentioned the
eternals are basically immortal and
they've already lived for
centuries so this could really be
anything as they've been around for a
very long time and have been a part of
ancient history
however this could be the city of the
space gods
the space gods are the celestials who we
know are going to be a part of this film
we've already seen our first look
and based off of everything that we know
the eternals actually serve the
celestials the celestials have charged
the eternals with the task of taking
care of earth
kind of makes you wonder where they were
during all of the events that the
avengers went through but i'm sure that
will be explained in this movie but in
the scene it kind of looks like
they are guarding it whoever the villain
of the movie is may be trying to break
into it we then go to sarah z saying
we're the ones who changed everything
now what she's most likely talking about
here
is the eternals influence in human
history
yes the eternals are tasked with
guarding earth but they also go
in and interact with humans and as
you've heard me mention
several of them have actually influenced
major parts in history on earth
and based off of what cersei is saying
here they could have been the cause of
some pretty big things
then the final scene of the eternals
teaser in this overall teaser trailer is
of camille nanjiani's character kingo
looking like a bollywood star he's got
the glasses on he's got the nice watch
on
it looks like he could even be filming a
movie it looks like it could be the set
of a movie but it looks like they have
stumbled upon something that they
weren't probably supposed to stumble
upon or perhaps some of the other
eternals are
actually going to get him based off of
what we know about this movie some of
the eternals have kind of left the main
group they went and lived life with the
normal humans this is why in the trailer
we see some of them in their normal
clothes but sometimes we see them decked
out in their eternal's gear
also this film is going to jump around
various different points in time
this has already been confirmed by kevin
feige the eternals are thousands and
thousands of years old we're going to
learn about when they were first created
all the way up to avengers endgame so
it's going to be pretty exciting to see
their origin
and what they've been up to this entire
time and how they come back together
in the film this is one of the marvel
projects that i am most
excited to see i think there's going to
be a lot of mcu history revealed
in this movie and i think it's going to
be very important moving forward
in the mcu so let me know what you
thought of this eternals teaser
in the comments down below let me know
how excited you are for this movie
don't forget to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all the latest mcu
news don't forget to like the video and
for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof
you